now. Welcome everybody to another Zoom call. I apologize in advance. I have a sore throat and a cold
or some reason. But here we go. Reider to look at the membership for announcements and
be checking there just like last week. Zoom call had to be canceled for the last second. So apologize
for that. And a reminder that you can self-schedule on our self-schedule page or on the member site
or in a billion other places. So make sure you look at that. Okay, first question. I am currently
trying vitamin C IVs and the ingredients are vitamin C, magnesium chloride, potassium chloride, calcium
aggluconate. Does that sound like a combination? Is there a reason why I should not do that? No,
no. You could do that. That's just fine. They are always in the vitamin C IV banks. There's other
minerals and it has to do with keeping it in solution and keeping it aqueous for the ability for you
to put it in your blood. So you don't really have a choice with some of these other things. They're not
putting it in there for you to get magnesium or potassium per se, but they're keeping it at the
pH balance for your blood. So that is just fine. I use my knife every single night for breast cancer
for the past week when I wake up at night and in the morning I am very dizzy. I read in the right
handbook to make sure you drink lots of water when you see the knife. If so, does that mean at night
or is it okay to drink enough adequate amounts of water during the day? Also, it is possible to
program that the program on my right needs to be changed. I'm doing very well. Also, could the
disease come from supplements I'm taking? So the dizziness is, I do, you know, so can you get dizzy
because you are dehydrated? So that's the initial thought in this question is that the right handbook
is make sure you're drinking plenty of water. Well, every therapy you're told to drink plenty of water.
They don't want you to be dehydrated. But the reason is that cellular dehydration can bring
about lots of other issues and it can affect the effectiveness of different therapies.
However, dehydration is typically not your first thing you think of when you think of dizziness
upon a rising and dizziness upon a waking. So you'd really want to ask a few more questions.
If you're, if you feel when you stand up from a sitting position or you get up and stand up
or even sit up from a lying position and you feel a little bit woozy, but then then you hold that
for 10, 15 seconds and it passes and then you're fine. Really what that suggests is a
dreidel insufficiency. So your adrenal gland kicks in a horrible that constricts your blood vessels
thereby increasing your blood pressure to shunt blood to your head so that you have adequate oxygen
supply upon rising from a sitting or lying position. That's how fast that hormonal progression works.
You're going to sit up from a sitting position, sit up from a right lying position. You literally
get at least 10 points elevation in your systolic blood pressure. Because of a sympathetic
told stimulation, because of a hormonal release, in order for you to
get adequate oxygenation to your brain. So if you don't get that, if that doesn't happen,
that is a side of adrenal insufficiency. So if that's the case, if you'd say, if the person says
what I get up at the middle of the night, I feel a little dizzy. And then it subsides
matter of a couple seconds to 20 seconds. And then I'm fine, but I just got to kind of brace myself
before I start walking. That's a side of adrenal insufficiency. So you really need to think about
taking some adaptogens, some adrenal stimulation. We have plenty of adrenal type things
to take. It could be a side of low cortisol in the middle of the night.
If you don't get, if that does not happen during the daytime, it's most likely you have it off
then you have it up blood sugar. It could also be a side of low blood sugar in the middle of the night.
So I don't think it has anything to do with hydration. And I don't think it has anything to do
with the rife. I don't think it has anything to do with any of your supplements taking. It's low blood
sugar, low adridels, and the adridels need sugar, and your brain needs sugar at the middle of the
night. So if you're already on a very low sugar diet because of your cancer and you're keeping your
glucose at low levels, and this is only happening at night, then it's most likely cortisol or glucose
or a combination thereof. So I would suggest you try adding some adaptogens or eating some protein
before you go to bed. So it's not about eating sugar, but it's about having not being hypoglycemic
in the middle of the night. So eating some protein that's going to break down slow
herb, well help maintain healthy. We'll do both things. We'll help maintain healthy
glycogen stores in a source of glucose and a source of stimulation of cortisol at night.
Regarding cancer in infrared solos, can I go to my local tanning facility that offers
infrared solos, or do I need to go elsewhere? If you want to do a sauna at the local tanning
facility, sure, you could do an infrared sauna there. If it's a small little business,
and they have infrared solos, for sure, go ahead and do that. That's fine.
Yeah, and remember, there's lots of different types of solos out there. Doesn't have to be near
infrared or far infrared or mixed infrared. A lot of the companies that sell solos really
talked, you know, they're selling their solos so they might advertise all sorts of different types
of infrared and their solos and stuff. But the truth is there's really very little true infrared
whether it's far or near infrared in any of these solos. So don't worry about that. You're not
using the solos to get infrared. Well, I can see the red light coming out of the plate that's far
infrared. So if it's a red light, it's not infrared. So infrared, far infrared, and near infrared,
will not have a color. It's below the red light spectrum. So if it is a red light, that is just
red light. Is that red light therapy beneficial? Oh, baby. I don't even know what the nano meters
of the red light that is being shown might just be a colored light. It's not really doing anything
to help you. It's the heat of the sauna that's beneficial. You're increasing your body temperature.
So you're sweating. So your detoxifying through your pores has really nothing to do with whether
it's infrared or not. People ask that other question. Can I just go to an old steam sauna and, you know,
an old one where you pour, you know, the water on the rocks and you don't have to pour water
on the rocks if you don't want the steam, but it's just an old heat source sauna. Yes, does the same
thing. You're not getting any increase benefit no matter what the company does. Who sell it? What
the company says in their advertisements that sell us on us, there's there's really no infrared
in the sun. So we have that true infrared heating, infrared source that we sell that hyperthermia
that we sell, we don't sell very many of them. It's not necessary for most people. And it doesn't go
that deep. It only goes an inch or two deep. So if you have a tumor site that's deeper than that,
it's not going to do anything for you. It's really for breast cancer. It's a good application for
however, there's no light that comes from it because it's 100% true infrared. So it doesn't show a
light. Plus it doesn't really heat that much. It's just warming at best. So it's not a source of heat.
So it's a lot of just false information out there, especially by these companies that maybe it's one
percentage for red that's actually being produced, but it's just a source of heat.
Should I be concerned about the amount of EMS in the bedroom, if the right, the generator and the
laptop are all on all night? Currently, I don't even leave my router turned on at night.
So where do you get EMS found in your house? Well, you get EMS that are produced locally
through electronics, through number one source of EMS in your house produced locally is your
is your Wi-Fi. That's the number one produced locally EMS. But you're also getting EMS from your
cell phones if they're plugged in next to you all day long. Because those are coming
not locally from the cell phone, but from the cell phone tower. It's still connecting all day long.
So you shouldn't leave your cell phone plugged in next to you in bed.
So the other sources of locally produced EMS are dirty EMS, dirty electricity from your
wiring of your house. Everybody's house is hardwired. And the number one source of external EMS that's
coming from the outside of your house is cell phone towers. And your outside meter, your electric
meter. So getting your meter cover can be really helpful. You can't do anything about cell phone
towers that are near you except moving away from one. Are you getting EMS from the right
machine from the generator itself? No, you're not getting any EMS from the generator.
Are you getting EMS from the bulb? No, you're not getting EMS from the laptop. Yes, if you leave
the laptop on, that's why we suggest you close the laptop. We'll need it to sleep. It's not
producing any more EMS. You can get an EMS reader because we've done that and measure it. It's not
producing any. So no, you do not need to be concerned about EMS in your bedroom from the right generator
and the laptop if you close the laptop at night. So again, number one source of EMS in your house
produced locally is your Wi-Fi. So it's the right thing to do, turn your Wi-Fi off at night,
dirty electricity. So think about getting a mitigator for dirty electricity. That is the things that we
have in our store and your meter on the outside of your house, think about getting the cover guard
for your meter than a little mesh cover guard that goes over it and tightens down on your meter cover.
We have that on ours both at the office and our house and all my staff has them at their house too.
Okay, let's see. Next question.
Dude, did you ever find out what the blood work pattern could indicate on to these slides?
Yeah, it was, I was correct when I mentioned it to you. It's most likely a bacterial infection
but the high monocytes also could indicate what I suggested to was EMS team bar as well.
But most likely bacteria, most likely it's H by Laura. That would indicate the
granular sites with the bacteria. It's kind of secondary EMS team bar that's resurfacing.
So EMS team bar is a virus that could live in the injured or ganglia forever and you can never
kill it. So a lot of viruses you could never totally kill because there's argument whether they're
actually most likely to live in organisms. So EMS team bar is one of those that can be dormant
in your system but then when you're compromised anyway that could come out. And that's what I'm
suspecting because that's what I mentioned. We talked about getting the liquid burberry from
Santa process but you said they don't make that anymore. Their liquid golden seal is extremely expensive.
You do have access to the core burberry by energetics that has barberry,
it coptus, or a gun grape, golden seal, and bulb. That would be a good substitute. So yes,
doses says 30 drops twice a day. Yeah, or you could just do, you know, try just 10 drops at every
feeding, not right now through the, and I think that product is fairly, it's not very viscous.
So I don't think you'll have a problem with it clogging up the feeding tube at all.
So I would get this, I would try this one. There isn't, you look, there's not really any other liquid
burberines on the market, but I would give this one a try. The company's a good company.
If you can't, somehow you can't get it, we can't order that. So let us know, let Megan know
when I can order that. We don't have it on the store, but I can order that.
I'm having continued issues with constipation, requiring at least one or two doses of BRLX.
Okay, well, we do not like anybody taking BRLX. It's a really, really poor source of any of a product
to help with constipation issues. So what's the best things to take for constipation?
Well, if it's just a mild constipation, I would start out with just taking some magnesium before bed.
If it's just like, I'm not, just don't feel like I'm having models, I just don't feel like I'm
really emptying my balls. Or if my issue is I have really difficult balls, I have hard balls,
that I would take magnesium. Now, when you take magnesium, you've got to make sure that you
couple that with taking an adequate amount of water. So a person can be constipated because of many
issues. So number one, they can be constipated because they're not digesting their fats or proteins
very well at all. That can be a major source of constipation. So how would you help support that?
You would take HCl and digestive enzymes. So taking something like clear digest, which has HCl
and digestive enzymes and support for the gallbladder, for the bile, that will help you digest your fats,
your proteins, and your carbohydrates, taking that with each meal. That's a digestive aid with each meal.
So that's the first thing that I'd consider. Second thing I'd consider, okay, well,
let's say I'm already taking that and I'm still having hard balls and it's difficulty to digest,
is start thinking, am I dehydrated? So am I even consuming enough water? So number two,
I would just start increasing my water consumption. Although that's not in, I drink plenty of water.
Okay, then add magnesium. You could be deficient in magnesium. If you, I mean, magnesium was needed
for hundreds of different metabolic processes in your body. So you can't really get too much magnesium
per se because it won't harm you. If you get too much magnesium, just dump it into the bowel.
Then water is drawn because it's an electrolyte and it'll help loosen your stools. Now, some people will
say I'm taking magnesium and I'm having bowel movements, but it's just really soft and it's hard to
know if you're really getting my balls really. It just feels like I'm not moving my balls very well.
Then use this. This is the phase six assist. Phase six assist is a type of aloe called
Cape aloe. Cape aloe helps get your bowel, your, your metabolic, the muscles around the ball moving.
It really helps you have a much better bowel movement. So if you feel like you're just
hey, let's say you went on a trip and you feel constipated or you change your diet,
you just feel constipated or you just feel like I've never really cleaned myself out. Take two of these
phase six assist, this Cape aloe before you go to bed and you'll have a really good bowel movement
the next day. This is not something that you necessarily need to be on on a daily basis. We do have
some people that have had surgery on their bowels. They have no connective tissue in their bowels and
they just always have difficulty with bowel movements that take this every day. But for the average
person that doesn't have colorectal cancer never had surgery and it doesn't, knows that they don't have
issues with any connective tissue in their bowels or any other issues that they've been tested on a
colonoscopy or something like that. Then just taking this as needed. So it's always good to have some
of this in your cabinet. It really doesn't go bad. Last for years and to take it, what do you need
when you feel like you're not getting yourself cleaned out? It's Cape aloe. Take a couple of these
before you go to bed with magnesium and with some water. It'll really help with your bowel movements.
Um, question coming. I just got my right machine. How close do you put the light to next to your
body? Well, it depends on if you have the amplifier connected. So if you have that jack hammer amplifier
connected to it, then you could put the bowl underneath the bed. It'll go right through the mattress and
it'll affect you a bit officially. Now, the amplifier is a relatively new addition to the right
machines. So most of our patients don't have that. Don't have the jackhammer. So they're putting the
bulb right next to them. They're snugly with the bulb. But if you have the amplifier, it amplifies
the frequency. So it gives it more power. So if you do put the bulb right next to you with the amplifier
connected, you might experience some static electricity. Somebody might come with your wife might come
and give you a kiss and she gets a shock. Okay. It's just static electricity. It's not dangerous. It's
electrostatic electricity. Electrons are forming on the outside of your body. So there's nothing
harmful. It's just like when you rub your feet with your socks on on the carpet and then you go touch
something. Actually, electrons are attaching to the outside of your body and then discharging when
you touch something else. So there's no harm in that. But it's not very comfortable. You know, if
somebody your wife reaches over and gets a shock every time she touches you or something like that.
So the reason why you would use the amplifier is because maybe you don't like the bulb next to you.
You want it under your bed. There's maybe reasons why you'd want it under your bed. You don't want it
right next to you. Personally, I don't use the amplifier. And again, most of our patients don't use
the amplifier and they just take that off and then just use it just the bulb connected directly to the
machine. Red and black connector. The red black outlet on the machine. And then you put the bulb
just next to you in your bed. That's my preferred way. The only reason why I would tell somebody to
use the amplifier and to put the bulb under the bed is if they just have issues with anything in bed
with them or they don't sleep with covers on it all and the light is annoying or something like that.
Is Cape Allo safe for kids? Most supplements are safe for kids, but you have to dose it based upon weight.
So it depends on the size of the child. If it's a three-year-old, that's only 30 pounds. You'd have
to literally open up a capsule and give them just a wee little bit. So I would never give a whole capsule
to a child on that weight. They probably have diarrhea all the next day. But there's no harm in Cape
Allo for children. It's just a matter of dosing it properly. So if you're very angry, you're taking two
capsules for somebody who's 160 pounds. How many are you going to give a 30-pound child? You're going to
do the math on that and you're going to just open up a capsule and give them a small portion of it.
Always with children too. With any supplements, you want to under-dose to begin with and then you
slowly build up to taller so you can see how they taller because some kids' systems will, you know,
it'll go through them and it'll, you know, then you wish you didn't do that. So
did you get my cheek swab? I wanted a schedule. I want to want to figure it out. No, what did you
bail on? I don't think I have your cheek swab. So I don't think so. Let me look. I did something
last week before I left. It was gone for a few days. No. I don't, I do not. So if you just sent it
then we just might not have gotten it. I felt two to three hard lumps in my armpit, left armpit
last week. Both doctors think it's congested lymph nodes and not cancer, doing self massage. Should I
expect lumps to soften or decrease in size based upon intensity and frequency of massage if it's
congested lymph nodes? So some of the things that would make you think it's an increased lymph node
is have you had a recent infection? I've had a cold, you know, something like that that could
cause that to take place. Was there any other changes where you exercise eat more or something like
that? Because you had surgery there's going to be it's going to be more easy to get lymph congestion.
So if any of those things take place, those give you a hint that it's that it's congestion. If you're
doing things to move live and it's chain, it's not changing size at all, then yeah, you, you know,
you have to at least think, well, I'll give this certain amount of time that I need to get this looked at.
But, you know, should I expect lumps to soften or decrease in size based on intensity and frequency
of massage if it's congested, gested lymph? If if it's due to an infection, you can increase the
size of the lymph node and it really depends on if the infection goes away, if your cold goes away
or whatever you have going on. If you don't have a cold, don't have any of that kind of history of
that going on. Yeah, you want to maybe give it a week to see a little change size. Okay, so if
let's say, let's say worst case scenario, it's cancer in those spots, you know, giving it more time
and doing some other things to try to move live isn't going to make it worse. So I would still give
more time and air on that side and do everything I can to to get motion in there and to get
moved out of there. So yeah, keep me informed on what happens with that. I'll be traveling next month
and don't want to miss my coffee in about time. It gets to be a lot of stuff to travel with. My
thought is to add boiling water to the grounds at night and let it set overnight to straight and use
in the morning thoughts tips or tricks. Okay, so go back to the course. Let me go on the course
really quick and see what or do I have it? Okay, so this page, I'm going to share
my screen with you real quick. Okay, so this is the call on the membership
site. So on the membership site, this is the page entitled Detoxification Details.
I have to see if this is uh, oh I guess it's not working. So we get um,
um, should YouTube that takes down videos of ours that literally the every week, we've
got such a fight with the world these days. So this, you get, you already know how to do coffee
animals. You're an expert at how to do coffee animals. However, I created an easy,
easy way to do coffee animals right here. This works really good if you're out and about.
So this first step, prepare coffee is what you're asking about. So literally when you're out
and when you're, uh, when you're traveling, just go get some organic coffee and make some coffee
in the morning and let it cool or add a little bit of water and do the easy peasy way
where you're standing in the shower doing the coffee animal. So just keep it really simple as I
wrote here. Just keep it really simple. Don't stress. You're doing a coffee animal.
Just stimulate your parasympathetics. If you're stressing about doing a coffee animal, you're,
you're, you're defeating the whole purpose of doing a coffee animal. You're stimulating your
sympathetic to try to stimulate your parasympathetics. So just, just do it super easy. If you know,
if you have to go buy a cup of coffee at a coffee shop, um, or if you have a coffee maker at wherever
you're traveling, just make some coffee, you know, it doesn't have to be done the perfect way.
So just do it, just do it that way. That would the way I would do it. Um, and, um, and make your coffee
and then do a standing coffee animal in the shower just to make it easy on your traveling.
I'm sending it in a urine sample next week at the moment. I am not on an antibiotic
for a minor UTI. Should I stop the antibiotic before sending it in the urine sample?
No. No. So if you're doing a urine, it depends on what you're doing the urine sample. So if you're
doing a urine sample, um, well, I'm trying to think of what a person would, what a test, your
urine sample test would make a difference if you're doing, if you're on an antibiotic and that'll
think there is any. So even if you did a urine sample to test for a UTI, um, you still wouldn't stop
an antibiotic because you're doing the antibiotic for a minor UTI. So you're trying to kill any
bacteria in there. So no, no, no, no, you don't have to, you don't have to stop the urine.
You don't have to stop the antibiotic for the urine sample for a microtox test,
nor do you have to stop it for urine sample for a glyphosate test. If that's what you're doing,
if it's the test that we sent you, then no, just do it. Do it tomorrow, if you can, or whatever,
do it. The earliest convenience would be better. The antibiotic should not interfere with that.
How would exercise congest the lymph? Well, exercise is going to increase circulation,
and then increase circulation is going to be dilation of your blood vessels, and you'll increase,
you know, capillary leakage, you know, you're hydrating the tissue, and
your muscles are calling for energy. So you need to increase the blood supply to the muscles.
So you're going to have more fluid that's going to need to be carried away than also. So exercise
is good for lymph flow too, but if you've had surgery, and it's blocking some of the pathways,
then that could be an issue. So typically, you want to do exercise to improve lymph flow,
because you're contracting muscles, and your moving the blood, and it's so good for every part of
your body, but if you've had surgery, that is, you know, damaged, you know, that is put basically a
dam in the stream that could be an issue. So it's really the change. Let's say, well, I haven't
done any exercise that I normally do, then that's not it. But if it's like, well, yeah, I was doing,
I had to go and do this. I was working out the garden. I was clearing this or something. I was,
I guess I did do a whole bunch more exercise than before. That could be it. So if it isn't anything,
you haven't done, if it's, if it's normal things, nothing is changed, then I wouldn't say that
would be it. But if there was a major change, that could be a factor. If I massage every day,
but also work out, will I maintain the status quo? Yes. I'll let you know if something is not good. So
it's really be the change. And you could have an infection that you, you know, maybe is, is
some clinical. So if you have a little cold or something like that, that can be an issue. You
don't realize that they're swelling. That's involved. Any other questions? Okay. Well, thank for
sake of my throat. We'll stop for today. And I'm sure you need anything specifically. Make sure you
go ahead and use that cell schedule page or get your questions submitted. We'll make sure we get
up. All right. Bye everybody. I'll see you next week. Bye-bye.